business owners tell me this all the
time they say like why should I make
videos for someone in Kansas City when
someone in Florida sees that you have 10
000 views on a video
they're going to become a customer a lot
faster as a an expert in your field we
want to build a community of people that
are are tuning in because they like you
this is what creates industry influencer
status well Owen welcome to the think
media a podcast I'm so excited that
you're here and I'm excited to dive into
some of your best tips for service-based
businesses yeah I'm excited to be here I
think the last time we were hanging out
it was over eggs benedict
um somewhere in Vegas so it's nice to be
in a different environment with you
again yes it's so exciting too how the
world of content creation the world of
YouTube can bring families together it
can bring people together and I I'm so
excited for this conversation because
you know even as a YouTube strategy
coach I think it's so worthwhile from
for people to hear from different
perspectives and you know you really
have honed in on the market when it
comes to that high performance coach for
service-based businesses which I think
is really special so I'd like to take it
all the way back though Owen because you
didn't just start out as Owen video
right let's just get a little backstory
about how Owen became Owen on YouTube
yeah absolutely well I've had a video
camera in my hand since I was about nine
years old you know my dad uh one year
for Christmas we didn't have a lot of
money there was two presents under the
tree and one was an original Nintendo
there was an original Nintendo under our
Christmas tree that year and a video
camera one of these big shoulder Mount
sort of like record your kids t-ball
game uh first generation uh video
cameras and I I had that video camera in
my hand uh for the next 20 years you
know and I was I was a hobby for me but
as I got into uh my career as a sales
person I was really burnt out I didn't
like it I could not hold a job and so
there was a moment for me where I'm like
I'm gonna go all in on this YouTube
thing and so what I what I did was now
at this time my camera was a lot fancier
but we were still using P2 cards I mean
this was really before the
um the the DSLR revolution had really
really happened I was carrying a
camcorder and I went knocking on doors
in downtown San Diego a place called La
Jolla and I had my video camera in my
hand and I said hey look I will do a
video for your business right now for 20
bucks but if I have to come back it's a
hundred bucks and so I would use those
20 videos you know I'd go do like 10 15
videos of a business and then that night
I'd go home and edit them I had a whole
like system like first this then this
than this and everyone got the same
music but they'd always call me back and
they'd say hey can you do our course can
you build our like our YouTube channel
can you build our Facebook ads and so
um that's how Owen video was was born
and shortly after you know I I burned
out on how many
how many videos I could film in a day I
started moving into coaching and that's
when we we sort of hired out
um the video production and instead I
began to coach and I was like hey if you
want to Excel on YouTube you know you
need to have like these seven videos and
especially for business owners you know
at the time we were serving you know
like the retail business uh or office
Parks so a lot of insurance companies a
lot of real estate companies
um and it was kind of like you need to
have like these 10 videos to attract
people but then you need to have these
10 videos to nurture them to sale and so
we we got really good at recognizing
what seven and eight figure businesses
needed to maintain an influencer status
on YouTube
um but also to create the kind of videos
that could reliably generate business
and I think that's what people know me
for now is is that if if you've got a
great company and you you want to
generate Revenue through YouTube you
know own videos the guy uh and I send so
many people to you also oh and I don't
know if you know this but I'm always
talking about you because you've really
honed in that Niche and and you said a
couple things there
um it was helping those business owners
one maintain status on YouTube because
you should be making entertaining style
valuable content right but also it
really just comes down to making the
sale getting a customer helping someone
grow their business and I think that's
what your specialty for me personally is
why I recommend you to so many business
owners because you really understand the
intricate details of what a business
owner specifically like you said in real
estate Insurance you know normal
everyday businesses not Mr Beast style
businesses right and you know that's a
lot of our clients will come to us and
they'll they're they're confused
um by all that and they say oh and I you
know I've got this company but I don't
want to make slime videos or my kids are
grown and I can't leverage my kids in
these videos and and you know you don't
have to you know the reality is is that
YouTube is is not just a place for cat
videos right like it's a place for all
the videos and so whether you're going
to see how to fix a a bathroom sink or
whether you're going to YouTube
um to see you know what the latest
fashions are everybody is is on YouTube
in in some way shape or form and so
having a good mix of videos that attract
new audience and bring thousands of new
eyeballs to your channel that's
important you just got to remember that
if you're slaying an insurance that's
Noble and that's admirable you're
probably not going to get 10 million
views on that video though right so
creating these reasonable baselines
where you say we tell our clients you
can expect a thousand to ten thousand
views on a video in your first 30 days
depending on the niche you're in it
depending on what like what the Market's
like right now so if you're in the
financial services right now I would be
making videos about the recession and
inflation and and how to avoid and
strategies out of or or
um you know 10 weird things to do in a
recession like that that can be
entertaining it has broad appeal but it
also brings the conversation back to
your business making some of those in
addition to having some of these like
nurture style how to buy an insurance
policy videos it's that mix that earns
you a place in the hearts of the
consumers so good and that actually just
leads us right into you know the first
tip we're gonna be sharing seven tips in
this podcast episode so make sure you
get your pen and paper ready because
Owen's gonna come with the fire he
always does and so I'm really excited
but tip number one uh for service-based
businesses and really defining that
right like service based businesses are
people that are serving other people
that's and we and I like to call them
quote unquote normal businesses right
like just a normal everyday business
that your uncle or your stepmom would
normally have right I mean it's a little
different
you know it's like you have the business
first before the YouTube channel right
whereas I think so many of the think
media audience is kind of like I'm gonna
I want to be YouTube as a Prof and I'll
I'll uh I'm a professional YouTuber and
I'll grow along the way whereas the
business owner is like I already have a
business
I already have customers now how do I
take that onto YouTube and grow by six
or seven figures that's kind of what
we're talking about exactly yes uh
really good Clarity on that because
there's so many people that think that
it's a you have to be a Creator first
and then a business owner I'm like no no
the people that actually win are the
business owners who learn how to become
content creators so tip number one is
you have to be making videos for
customers first I love that this was
really the first tip because even though
YouTube has you in it it's actually the
wrong you yeah you is the person you
serve that's who you're actually making
videos for why is that like the number
one tip for service-based businesses
yeah well you know as business owners we
have a built-in audience where as a
Creator who who's going to start a
channel on
um uh model airplanes
that person starts with zero there's no
audience built in you got to start
making videos and just climb all the way
up where as a business owner you already
have customers
and they already need videos from you so
you should start making videos for them
first you you need to have a vehicle by
which you make a video and then you push
it to your customers through email or
social media right versus putting up
like a challenge video and then hoping
it gains an audience and then somehow
making that audience a customer because
now what you're doing is you're serving
two masters right you're like trying to
like be famous on YouTube well at the
same time like trying to serve your
business serve your customers and your
pre-customers right so the people that
aren't customers yet but they're they're
in they're looking right make videos for
them first cut your chops on that right
learn how to get video edited quickly
learn how to perfect your message to
people that are already willing to give
you some slack so that you get that
watch time up right because these people
will watch it oh my my real estate agent
sent me a video I better watch it or or
you know the restaurant down the way
sent me a video I'm gonna watch that get
your watch time up and like learn how to
respond to an audience or get an
audience to respond to you by serving
customers first and then working towards
things like triggering their the
algorithm yeah I think it's really
important too especially when you are a
business owner and you're coming into
creating content it's really
understanding that you're duplicating
Yourself by being able to make those
videos which is such an incredible thing
as a business owner especially if you
think about you know a real estate agent
who maybe is servicing eight clients at
one time with all the questions that are
coming in you can duplicate yourself by
just creating a video that answers the
questions your customers oh yeah and
like walking them through onboarding you
know
um all of those videos are so valuable
it's how I built my channel I had a
whole bunch of unlisted videos that just
onboarded people to to my company but
those got watch time and just because
they're unlisted doesn't mean that you
don't still show up in their news feeds
so when you're like hey all of my videos
are on they're unlisted on YouTube your
clients are watching these they're
building up watch time and then they go
onto YouTube casually and guess what
they see in the recommended section they
see your public facing videos so I think
a lot of times what business owners do
is they want to get famous and it's okay
it's okay to want to be famous on
YouTube we all want a little bit of
Industry Fame and I think embracing that
is important but you also don't want to
leave your customers hanging right like
make don't Focus so much on the eight
zany things I did with my blah blah blah
right like focus on stuff that's going
to build the the company so that you're
earning revenue and that's paying for
your editing and that's paying for your
videographer whatever the case might be
and you just triggered the next uh tip
which is actually it's not just about
the videos you're making on YouTube as
as a business owner it's really about
what is the pathway that you have your
customers going through and what does
that look like when it comes to
understanding how to be a video creator
as a business owner yeah so I just had a
meeting with the eight figure Insurance
brand that's why insurance is on on my
mind and I asked them the question
what what landing page are your your
people coming in on from from your ads
and from your social media and
they had no answer it was well just our
website and and on my website there's a
contact page and then before you get to
that contact page there's like an eight
page form and you got to fill out you
know before you fill out the contact
page
um and it's like well we want them to be
qualified before they reach us and I
said how many people are filling out
that form goose egg none so you're like
you got to figure that out you know we
we may have called this your funnel in
the past and and I I believe in funnels
but I feel like that word
kind of brings up a lot of painful
memories for for people because we're
not like funnel marketers right we're
YouTube marketers but you do need to
have a landing page that people can give
you their name and email and that
landing page should go to a thank you
page where where now you're upselling
your offer or a 15-minute call
before they even get the email from you
so
what happens is you start to make videos
for your company
and you get a phone call from someone or
an email and and they're like hey you
know I saw your video on YouTube I want
to buy from you yay
but then they're going to tell you
something like by the way it was really
hard to find you
know by had to Google you and that's not
what you want so you want to make sure
that you have an e-book or uh if it's a
15-minute call that's okay too remember
like
so many of us use calendly and other
calendar Services as I do but that's
never the first page I send someone to
first I send them to a capture page
where there's a name and an email that
way I get the lead okay and then from
there they'll go to a page that has
another video that's like do you want to
get on a 15-minute call and that goes to
the calendly so there's there's a couple
extra clicks there but the reason that
that's important is because it's
intentional you you want to have
enough steps in your funnel in your
conversion pathway
to disqualify the lazy people right so
like it's it's easy to put like name and
email get your ebook
um and then unsubscribe right
but we get name and email and then on a
thank you page we we get it we keep them
there with a short video that extols the
value of like let's just get on a call
man like hey you know and our whole
thing is like hey we were all locked in
our houses for two years let's get
together let's do a zoom call let's
let's just find out if we're a good fit
you know and I'm doing two different
things here I'm keeping people on my
asset my website all right which is
telling Google and all the other places
that my website is valuable so all that
stuff I don't use click funnels and I
don't use third-party pages I build them
into my WordPress site so that they're
staying on my site okay the second thing
that I'm doing is I'm using video to
upsell them to an appointment where I
have a structured pitch for them so you
know if you're a service if you're a
HVAC company
and you're you're kind of used to people
just
they they fill out your form at 2 A.M
because the hot water heater exploded
like how do you get someone before the
hot water heater explodes right you
probably will need to create a new page
in your conversion pathway so that when
you when someone wants to find you they
can find you easily
so so good it reminds me of my husband
and I were looking for a new landscaper
and I was shocked at how uh at how
unadvanced the landscaping companies
were I'm like are you gonna text me that
you're coming is it really at a point
yeah are we what are we doing are there
what are the services that you offer I
had so many questions and I as a
marketer was so triggered and I thought
Dang if this person would have just
created a landing page that told me what
they do and then said hey we'd love to
you know also partner with so-and-so who
cleans the gutters or whatever it like
there's so many opportunities yeah for
businesses to increase their revenue by
doing simple things like making a video
on a landing page and that's not even
the YouTube side right that's that's
that's after someone's watched your
YouTube videos but man when the student
is ready the teacher appears and if you
can be that teacher in the moment you
can get someone into your I love how you
call that the conversion pathway yeah
that's what we're trying to do is
convert the Right audience and I love
also that piece oh and you said of
deterring the wrong person because we
don't want to waste time we don't need
to be with the wrong people we want the
right people that want the right offer
that we are offering and I love how you
put that together yeah you do that
through your videos you know you do that
through your videos you don't need to
complicate it kind of like the old world
marketing and it's old world it's just
like five years ago where it's like you
have 10 different free offers
um and and there's I get it some some
companies just kind of have that
infrastructure like we've been doing
this so long we actually have like four
or five free offers out there
um but at the end of the day it's kind
of like go to our YouTube channel
if you don't like us then don't opt in
right like yeah you'll find an opt-in
from there you just got to make sure
that that you have that and it's not a
contact page on your website it needs to
be very specific like I watch your video
and want to talk to you like as simple
as that like give them a way to to to
give you a name and email I love that
you keep it so simple now here's the
problem though is a lot of times when
business owners are coming onto YouTube
or when they're even getting in front of
the camera they can one act weird right
or two they actually try to be like
these famous entertainment YouTubers now
what's your caution and your tip for
business owners coming online so good
it's don't be a YouTuber you know I love
YouTubers some of our closest friends
are YouTubers
um I myself have a sketch comedy channel
with my family that I do on Tick Tock
and it's sort of a passion project but
you know your unboxing is it may not be
that exciting
to your audience and then like the the
fluorescent purple thumbnails
um you know probably you need to
maintain a certain level of
professionalism and I find that a lot of
our clients actually exhale at this tip
right they go oh thank goodness because
like I didn't want to do slime videos
and you don't you don't have to I think
that what a a professional video
business does uh you know any business
that's that's publishing to YouTube is
you want to be fun and have character
and even in my videos you guys will see
that I'm sort of like struggling to
smile because I I want to say this right
and we're launching a new product and
I'm so proud of this product I don't
want to mess it up like
that's natural
but what you don't want to do is kind of
like overact and zainify like whoa did
you see this new Plumbing special from
the plumbing docks you know it's like
dude you're a plumber like just gotta be
like a cool plumber you know like
try to understand that YouTubers are
content creators first you're a business
owner first and you should maintain a
certain level of professionalism yeah
and I think you I love that exhale
because especially coming into the
platform if you've been running an
insurance company or you've been an HVAC
person or a plumber for the last 10 20
years all of this is so new because
you've been focusing on growing your
business so the the images that you see
or the things the videos that maybe you
watch for entertainment don't have to be
the type that you're doing and one thing
that I see Owen is and I commented
before is just how professional your
background even looks you know like just
even the setting that you're creating
your videos in really matters to the
audience that's going to be watching
them and and so I love that you said you
don't have to be a YouTuber with the
fluorescence everything it can just look
like an office it can just look like a
nice living room or whatever that it
actually adds to The credibility too you
know like if you're a doctor we work
with a lot of functional medicine
doctors um and Physicians you know and
it's like you don't you don't want to
have like a a distracting background I
want to log in and feel your
professionalism and that hooks me you
know I'm sure you guys have seen this
too is that people on YouTube are are
pressing play on the video and then
putting it in their pocket
um and listening to videos for for
longer forms and podcast platforms are
are struggling and different things
that's a real interesting thing people
want to see that they can trust you and
then stop looking at you and I I find
like so de-emphasize like have what you
need to have but nothing more
this video is sponsored by stream yard
this is our go-to platform for live
streaming to YouTube and Facebook
especially when we have multiple people
joining us on a stream with an
incredibly easy to use interface for
doing cool transitions bringing in text
on the screen and seamlessly bringing on
guests this is the perfect platform for
the new and experienced creators alike
you can use the link that we have in the
description below to get 10 off
well your next tip when it comes to
being a business owner is that you
should be building a community why is
this so important that you say community
versus customers and why is it important
oh it's so important to like have a
community of people that that you will
never be able to serve you know
business owners tell me this all the
time they say like why should I make
videos for someone in Kansas City when
they'll never be able to buy from me uh
you know I'm in Florida like why should
someone over there Karen and the whole
thing is
when someone in Florida sees that you
have 10 000 views on a video
they're going to become a customer a lot
faster and so you know as a an expert in
your field whether that's we've been
mentioning insurance but maybe it's real
estate I served a client that that does
epoxy resin coatings
we want to build a community of people
that are are tuning in because they like
you and and this is what creates
industry influencer status when when all
the people in your industry point to you
as one of their influencers one of the
people that they look up to that lends
itself so much credibility so so Number
One You're Building your industry
credibility
um with with that approach but number
two you're also creating a community
that self-propels your content you've
got let's say a a volley group volley is
is sort of like the new alternative to
Facebook groups and we love the volley
app if you've got this this group of of
people some of them can buy from you
some of them can't but you're doing like
FAQs with them and you're getting
questions and feedback from them that
can become your future videos right you
could even feature them in your videos
say this question question came from
Heather who's in our community on on
volley and and making Heather the
celebrity for the day my in fact our
good friend Ben Azadi does this with his
podcast he uh a comment of the week and
he makes one of his audience members a
celebrity when you do this you become
uh you have this self-propelling content
wheel that makes it so you don't have to
come up with any more ideas and this is
a really exciting place for you to be
the the last reason and there's so many
reasons to build community I mean the
altruism I believe in scholarships and
and we we I mean scholarships for me
because we have a program so we like to
pick someone from our community and give
them a scholarship there's someone that
normally wouldn't be able to afford US
um and then they get to start meeting
with seven and eight figure you know
entrepreneurs on on these calls it's
like a wonderful experience for them so
there's like this giving back
um sort of sort of the pillars altruism
too there's lots of good reasons but
most importantly is that the chances of
converting a client
you know over a YouTube video cold
are are not as likely as you converting
a Community member to a sale so you kind
of look at your your group as an
incubator and you want to put your all
the people who like you right
in that group and then from there that's
where you do your webinars and that's
where you do your live stream
presentations right that's where you
convert the low-hanging fruit of your
community into customers so you know
build communities and not just customer
bases and and what you'll find is that
you'll you'll be incubating referrals
you'll be incubating new sales and
you'll be incubating this like altruism
in your community that I you know I'd
say it's it's outside of non-profit work
it's it's really hard to duplicate that
it's so true and I've seen this happen
even for our own students it reminds me
of Dr Eye Health he's an eye doctor I
think in Minnesota in a in a small
practice right and he was serving
clients every single day serving
customers every single day as an
optometrist and he started his YouTube
channel first he was nervous to do it
because he was like I went to school I
did my residency I opened a practice now
I'm going to make free content on the
internet you know like he had that
mindset to a while that he did and
what's incredible is that now he because
of the power of YouTube and creating
content for his ideal customer which is
people interested in Optometry right
like contacts versus glasses what are
eye floaters like very simple questions
um he now only works two days a week in
the office because he wants to because
he wants to still serve his local
audience but he's now traveling and
speaking to tons of different Medical
Professional conferences because he's
now the number one eye doctor he's an
influencer he's an influencer and then
he also now because of the brand deals
that he's got with certain contacts and
certain um Optometry uh items you know
just putting that in a bucket
um he's making doctor level income on
the side that's because of the power of
YouTube and here's what you could have
done Owen he could have said well I'm
only in you know Minnesota I should only
make videos for people in Minnesota and
he finally caught the vision that no no
no this goes bigger than that there's a
bigger conversation happening and I wish
more business business owners would see
that because they're going to be the
examples to the generation coming up
behind them who aren't going to be able
to be Mr Beast right they're going to
need to own businesses and make content
to be able to have those those
businesses and creating Community I love
that you said that because it's such a
key to Growing massive not just staying
so singular in your one location yeah
it's not all about sales right like
that's the old model the old model is
like I gotta make sales every day
you know the the new model is Community
Driven it's not like that's where you're
monetized guys it's you know you're
monetized through customer traffic but
you you don't have to cold recruit on
YouTube you just get people in your
community and then from there we've got
a doctor client out here in in Salt Lake
city that has YouTube clients flying in
to see him so we're limited only by kind
of our thinking and and I love that
example I love that the eye doctor had
to catch the vision I know right did you
catch them in there somewhere it was
good you know and and I'm just gonna hit
this one more point I am a product of
that I was searching for an alternative
to braces and one of the things that I
found was even just how um I uh just
things in my mouth and there's a doctor
in San Diego who does more of a holistic
approach so I'm gonna go to a doctor in
San Diego because they were making
content on the internet like oh and this
is where it can go when you're coming
I love this kind of conversation let me
tell you it's so much fun
um okay number five though uh we gotta
we gotta break this down into simple
things and first before you do anything
you gotta reverse engineer where are you
going but you gotta start with a goal
why is that a tip for business owners
because business owners enter YouTube in
a scarcity mindset and you go I don't
know if this is gonna work
I don't know how long I'm gonna do this
so I'm gonna make one video
that
says everything
and we call this a super video and this
one video is supposed to get you a
million subscribers it's supposed to go
viral it's supposed to generate sales
and give you your Roi all within the
same seven day period right and and this
is very common right and I'm I'm
embellishing a little bit because it's
not one video but you think you're gonna
make three videos and then I'll see how
it works
that's not how it works right when I say
focus on a goal what you need to do is
is create a set of videos a series a
playlist a silo a handful of videos that
all are determined to achieve a certain
goal so for example I'm gonna I'm an eye
doctor and I'm gonna make a series of
videos that are designed to grow my
subscribers
and every video you're not really even
focused on the views on those videos
you're only interested in did they get
subscribers okay and you compose that
video
for that goal similarly you might have
another set of videos that you you say I
want these videos to get views so
they're they're maybe going to have uh
more broad uh topic
um appeal maybe the the the titles
themselves will be a little bit more
um inflammatory uh less how-to uh and
more more suggested algorithm style
titles
but you're going to take a different
approach to those videos and then you're
going to have another set of videos that
are just designed to make sales now if
you make a video that's designed to make
sales and it goes viral gets you 10 subs
and makes a sale
well Hallelujah brother like right on
but you go into it with one video One
purpose right this video is designed to
get views and what this does for you is
it focuses your energies on the metric
you wanna you wanna move
but it also takes the pressure
off of the video creation so you don't
need it to be this perfect video you
need it to accomplish this one thing so
we say it's never one video it's always
five videos right if you're gonna do a
video about ice skating it's never one
video about ice skating it's five videos
on ice skating in fact uh
patrickbetdavid at
um grow with video it mentioned this on
stage and I was just like that's that's
what we tell people
um you know you've you make videos in
sets and then you're you're looking at
the analytics on that set right when you
go into video hoping that one video will
do all these things you're gonna get
disappointed and that disappointment
Loop that you know that having
unrealistic expectations and then the
expectations not met and now you're
depressed and so now you make another
video in scarcity like
that that's not going to get you
anywhere so one video One goal and by
the way it's never one video it's always
five videos I love that so much I like
to say you got to be committed to the
process not the product and when it
comes to that if you're like I'm gonna
go all in on YouTube that's the other
thing if you're gonna set a goal go all
in on it don't just dabble with it like
go all in
um because as you start to set those
metric goals as you start to set those
you know one video One video
um a goal idea that's where you're gonna
start to see momentum
um and really trying to figure out what
kind of videos you like to make I think
yeah people make like one or two videos
and they're like I don't know if it's
working I'm like I don't know if you're
working like do you understand that this
this is going to take a little bit of
time look happy in these videos it's
like I have a client just yesterday and
it's like you don't look happy and in
fact you look kind of miserable do you
enjoy making these videos she goes no I
don't I said well they're not getting
any views so let's stop making them you
know and I asked her I said what videos
do you want to make and she goes
honestly I want to go like to the new
restaurant that opened up and Food
review it and I want to go to the new
coffee shop and I was like fly little
bird and be free go do that the energy
that you'll take into making your own
and then you you link it back to she's a
real estate agent you think back to real
estate hey for more on this town you
know lot log into to my channel so I
think that's a really great Point really
really good now as business owners Owen
we know that sometimes you've got
Seasons where it's gonna be uh you know
you've got more time and sometimes
there's seasons of life that you don't
and so one of your tips was don't be
afraid to take a break and when I read
that I was like ah there's permission in
that oh and why is that so important
yeah I mean and we operate in these
hyper intense circles day in and day out
and and Heather you know you know my
story but for our listeners out there I
was diagnosed with stage four terminal
cancer two years ago the doctor told me
to get my Affairs in order this is just
two years ago and you know I went home
super mega you know depressed and and
once I got out of that
um I went to YouTube and I found
different ways to be cancer and now here
I am before you healthier than I've been
in my entire life my last scans were so
unbelievable I couldn't even recognize
any cancer in my body and and all of
that was was you know due to the the
knowledge and Grace of the Lord but my
point is this I worked myself into
cancer I did and it was the the
nighttime hustle of like work during the
day make videos at night while I'm
drinking Mountain Dews and eating
twinkies and then minimal sleep wake up
have a sugar-based protein shake off to
the gym hustle hustle hustle come back
home be the best dad ever I had I had
never taken time to just rest and
re-center my life and in my body it
exploded as cancer and others it's going
to be autoimmune disease
um you know it might be obesity it might
be depression it might be ADHD it might
be divorce and and here's the thing this
is never what what God or nature had
intended for our lives our lives are
meant to be lived in swings where where
we're running from a lion in the daytime
but at night time we're singing around
the campfire and the problem with
YouTube is we get into this comparison
Zone a lot I know as soon as Instagram
real like I get into it with Instagram
reels because I'm I could be doing that
oh man I gotta do something like this I
love you know and I get in this
comparison Zone what I want to encourage
especially business owners to do because
we're of the same you know fold is
create in Seasons where you're going to
create 22 videos over the next 90 days
and then you're gonna break you're gonna
take three weeks off from video creation
maybe not from work but you're gonna
take three weeks off and enjoy the
fruits of your labor friend like I want
you to just take a step back and breathe
remind yourself that your value is not
in your views right remind yourself that
that like hey I'm not in this thing to
compare myself with Sean or with Omar
right I'm here to to be the best me that
I can be and and when you get into that
that zone right now it's time to rev
your engine and go back up and do 22
more videos but you've really gotta pace
yourself and create Cadence in your life
where you are doing the work you love to
do with type A personality mode
but you're also relaxing as such with um
with some equal attention so that your
body can stay in Balance so I firmly
believe I'm anti-workaholism uh I am
anti-hustle culture I'm all about the
grind okay I work hard 10 hours a day
but at 10 hours I'm a dad at 10 hours
I'm a husband and and that's and
sometimes I'm the lazy guy watching
Seinfeld on the couch
you know make time for that stuff in
your life smell the roses because we're
in this for the Long Haul yeah and
that's so powerful and thank you so much
Owen for uh being vulnerable and sharing
your story of what that even looks like
and I I see this happen so much when
people get into content creation because
it feels like it's just this cycle That
Never Ends you gotta get a new video you
got to do the thing and I'm like whoa
whoa I'm on this for the next decade
like I it's okay to take it's okay to
take some time off it's okay if a video
doesn't go out every single week and I
like to even think about
um things in like actually series and
Seasons so for our podcast like we're
doing right now it's gonna be in a
season and then guess what we're gonna
do the best of and we're gonna repost
the same videos with a new intro right
and we're gonna just allow for um us to
have that season of rest now that I've
been doing this gosh I've been in
digital marketing for for over a decade
now and video creation for the last
seven years
um it feels like it's never ending and
guess what friend if you're trying to
make big impact in the world it will
never end so you've got to pace yourself
through that journey and also Seasons um
you know I love you hit on that
comparison piece Owen because I do this
to myself you know a lot of the female
content creators that are doing things
um they don't have three children they
didn't adopt a child they did it you
know like so though so I'm comparing
even my life stage with other people who
are not even in that same life stage I
don't have people or they don't have
children which is fine but they have
more opportunity because I have to say
no I get to say no no I get to say no to
other things because I'm choosing to
pour into my family so thank you for for
bringing that part that's so good I have
four kids too and you know like I I they
almost lost their dad because I was so
afraid
of not making enough money or or so
afraid that I wouldn't be invited to the
next conference to speak you know that I
worked myself into this thing trying to
protect my kids when in reality I put
them at more risk
um so I think it's it's very important
that we recognize the need for rest so
so good
um well and lastly um one of the things
that I think is so important for any
business owner um I actually just had a
real go out today about this um that I
didn't make by the way my team did thank
you for having team
um thank you team uh is um invest in
other people and I said today that that
actually the best currency is relational
currency and I think if you can just be
a good friend if you could be someone
who shows up to the to the thing and
serves others well I believe that comes
back to you 10 100 fold and so your tip
was as a business owner invest in other
people what does that mean for you and
how should business owners apply that as
they hit into this next season
celebrate the Winds of your colleagues
okay which means like the competitor
down the street when when he does well
congratulate him right and and resist
the urge to darn that George like I'm
gonna catch up to him someday like that
just foments sort of that that ugly
cycle in your body just I struggled with
this for a long time uh being unable to
congratulate my peers even people that
were not
competitors to me right like I I'd see a
a dentist Channel blow up and it's like
man I want my channel blow up that way
and you know so you get it so number one
is get in the habit of liking and
congratulating people right when you see
they're doing well just congratulate
them
um I I feel like the video Community is
really great at this and it just
celebrating each other's wins whether
publicly or privately I have some some
colleagues that I compete with right
like
there a business is either going to
choose me or them so I'm not always
commenting publicly on their videos
because there's a brand thing there but
I am dming him and I'm going hey that
was a great video bro congrats on that I
saw I saw the response you got on that
you know and it creates an air of
Goodwill so that's that's number one
what I mean by investing in others like
celebrating wins uh with people that
that may may actually
be a competitor to you but two is I I
really want to see companies
um offering apprenticeships and
mentoring and in some way or shape or
form of giving back to the community so
you know if if you're uh uh we mentioned
earlier a uh epoxy countertop company
find a non-profit to to do some epoxy
for right and involve your YouTube
Community invest in that in that
community and say Hey you know we're
gonna go do all the countertops for this
Boys and Girls Club
um uh down in the city and you the
viewer can help us pay for it right by
and you raise some money it maybe it
covers costs maybe it just covers lunch
you're gonna do it one way or the other
I think that's extremely valuable uh I'm
a business coach and and I coach seven
and eight figure companies but you know
there are people out there that I love
that can't afford my program and we try
to pick someone every quarter that we
can give a scholarship to and we can say
come on in and be a part of the group
and I'll tell you that's that's
something that I really enjoy personally
because number one is it it connects me
with someone who I love and respect but
maybe don't get to spend professional
time with and two because
they now get to be a part of this
community of business owners
that is probably a level or two above
them and they get to kind of now learn
from them as well and be a part of this
this group and I really love that I
really like kind of like looking at
seeing one of my my the guys I Mentor
kind of in this group like
like I can't believe I'm in this this
Mastermind with so and so or with that
channel whatever the case might be
there's um there's a lot of value that
comes in investing in in others so
whether you're giving away
your product to like a charity or
mentoring someone in your channel right
like if you're a Creator Channel and
you're thinking how how can I invest in
others like how to give someone give one
person a month a channel review in your
audience or
um like there's one guy in your audience
that um I just he reviews baby toys
um his kids probably aren't even babies
anymore but you know maybe put together
a package every quarter and just give it
to someone in your a bunch of toys that
the brand sent you you know like find a
creative way to just give back asking
for nothing you don't need to Market it
it doesn't need to be a press release
just do something cool for somebody I I
think it'll change the way that you're
you feel when you wake up in the morning
so it's incredibly powerful so so
powerful to lean into that and you know
you got me you got me sparked too Owen
I'm like gosh what could we do as think
media I mean we we definitely do
different types of uh reach outs and and
um and I do agree our community the
video content creation Community I mean
the fact that Owen it's we're friends
and we're competitors and you know it's
it's amazing that um I believe that when
we when one Rises we all rise and the
way I look at it is rather than looking
at her and tearing her down I go if she
can do it I can do it like if she can
make it I can make it and 100 yes I
think that's so so incredibly powerful
but investing in people you know I uh
right now we were just having a
conversation
um around a dinner table with some uh
some parents that have some teens that
are interested in video content creation
and I told him I was like man like we
need a school for these kids kids
because business owners need shredditers
and they need good editors and they need
people to understand these modern skills
and I'm just and I was thinking I should
just create a free school that's what I
should do oh and just help people do all
the things or even like a weekend a
weekend retreat like a weekend Workshop
I did that for my church out in San
Diego I did like an editing Workshop I
brought in my green screen and and it
was just an afternoon and nothing came
of it I think even when I did it part of
me was like you know somebody will see
this and turn it into like there was
still that hope of of of return
um but once I got into I never even
thought about it was just so much fun to
work with those young kids mostly in our
youth program and and just say like hey
this is actually like a legit career
path you know what I mean so I love it I
love anything that you guys you guys
have such a strong Community too right
it's it's just an awesome opportunity to
say thank you to your audience right
like hey as a ways and thank you to all
of you who have made us who we are we're
going to do something for this person
you know that's what the YouTube
community did for me my mentor derral
Eves did a 24-hour live stream to raise
money for my cancer treatment and they
raised over a hundred thousand dollars
Daryl gave me that money
I mean it was in my bank account there
was no sense of you don't need to do
anything you don't need to tweet it out
for me or or he just said sit at home
and turn on YouTube at this time he said
that's all I want you to do and I sat
there and I cried I did like a little
baby watching all my friends donate
money to my my cancer cause there's guys
you could do stuff like that raise money
for a kid I mean there's there's so much
need
um it shouldn't be hard to find
somewhere to fill so good well on that
Owen I just have to say um it's just
such a pleasure to have you on the think
media podcast thank you for just being
such a great friend for being such an
honorable man who's you know really even
through the hard things you're still
going after your goals what an
incredible example to your children you
are and it's just so awesome to get to
uh you know be on this journey with you
and be able to help as many people as we
can but I just want to honor you and
just say thank you for being such an
incredible man who's showing up for
people every single day
um and it's just it's amazing to see
what you're able to create when you
really put your mind to it so thank you
Owen for being a part of what we're
doing
um I want to let people know that uh if
you like this uh go and subscribe over
on Owen's YouTube channel you've got
some incredible new things coming out on
the YouTube channel so I'm really
excited for that and then uh also if
you're a service-based business owner
let us know down in the comments below I
know Owen likes to creep the comments
just like I do and so if you've got a
question that you'd like to ask Owen you
can do it in our comment section or head
over to his YouTube channel ask away
subscribe and ask him there
so good well thank you Owen uh we'll
catch you in the next episode
thanks so much for having me
[Music]